[Music]
and he spotted the last man as well now
rapping
back into ct and sicko gets it done
they find the victory a dominant one at
that they
send complexity home that is the worst
way to get eliminated from a tournament
it certainly signaled his
dissatisfaction with
team with their performances and from
the second that we all saw that tweet we
knew the changes were coming
it might not matter oh magus he had the
hell for it but now he's been taken out
and sip
just trying to buy time flank it around
blame it hunting him down
he turns for it immediate defuse he's
right there with the kid oh my god i
can't believe it's 16 and 12.
complexity taking down australis that
first big win for us that like kind of
got us past not past but like a little
bit past the names you know
which i think we've kind of embraced at
this point it's not like that much of a
meme anymore because we are a juggernaut
movie
i've seen every big cs goal match ever i
can tell you that would already be like
a top five upset of all time
it's looking real good for complexity
maybe close this out
oboe continuing the defense downstairs
and it's all on the suture he's gonna
get dropping 16 to 12.
complexity are your champions ladies and
gentlemen
complexity is one of the oldest
organizations in esports dating back to
the early 2000s
everyone goes oh complex it's never
gonna be good you can't buy chemistry
look at the chemistry they're displaying
now it's looking pretty good
jason lake founded the organization
after hearing about esports from a
friend and falling in love with the
industry almost 20 years ago
after i finished law school i was just
kind of hanging out for a while and
traveling and
just kind of taking a break and i walked
into a friend's apartment
and he's playing counter-strike i was
just fascinated i'm like there's teams
there's events you can go play you can
win money i'm like this is the perfect
like intersection of like competition
in my love for video games so i'm like
esports
complexity built one of the greatest
teams in north american
cs 1.6 history winning two different
majors
but even after the multi-million dollar
cgs league imploded in 2008
complexity was one of the few
organizations to survive
but just barely we're going to chase the
esports stream man we moved all the way
across the country to la
this is in may of 2008 that summer the
economy completely tanked
and that november they shut down the
whole league so i'd gone from owning
complexity owning a law firm
to literally being unemployed in a state
that i wasn't licensed to practice law
and
we went from a successful pretty
comfortable life
to chasing the esports dream and lost
everything we had to move into this
little itty bitty tiny house
we had no money i was like scrambling
just trying to figure out
you know what to do to put food on the
table but despite all of that success in
1.6
complexity has been lackluster when it
comes to cs go
although the veteran org found some
success at the beginning of cs go's
lifespan
they dropped off as the years progressed
complexity's csgo division was a shadow
of their 1.6 days
with the team finding little success
save for the occasional surprise
tournament run the more exciting thing i
think for for
complexity is the sense of these are
names that nobody here would be really
expecting to see on this stage at all
right these are names who you know if
unless you really watch north american
counter-strike you wouldn't know a lot
about
yeah but it is hard work and dedication
which is going to be a common theme i
imagine
when we delve deeper into the stories of
the players stepping onto the
quarter-final stage
uh the likes of uh android yay these are
players who
it is their first major and their first
major they make top eight like that's
that feels like an achievement in itself
how far they can go
is our conversation next even after
getting the backing of jerry jones and
the dallas cowboys jason lake and
complexity
had a hard time signing top tier talent
they did the best with the pieces they
had
but their best just wasn't that great
and after bombing out of the 2019 berlin
major
jason lake was done with losing
in what's now one of the most infamous
tweets in cs go history
lake called out to any and all tier 1
talent in cs go
sure that tweet might have been a bit
insensitive to his current roster but it
also expresses his burning desire
to see complexity win this is this is
what's great about this tweet is all the
people who say it's unprofessional like
it might not be your style and you might
not like it and that's fine
but there's nothing more professional
than essentially saying that
you're you're in it to win and your your
organization is in it to find the best
talent bring it in
and improve over the next few months
lake completely rebuilt
complexity with only oboe remaining from
that previous roster
first came blame f from heroic and rush
from cloud9
and in november complexity completed
their new roster by signing config
and poison and in their first offline
tournament together complexity beat the
best
team in the world our sip will find a
kill and blame f
maybe a rare chance there they need to
get on and defuse that bomb right now
complexity two on two they have a slight
health advantage but
against these weapons for astralis it
might not matter
oh magus he had the hell for it but now
he's been taken out and sip
just trying to buy time flank it around
blame it hunting him down
he turns for it immediate defuse he's
right there with the kid
oh my god i can't believe it's 16 and
12.
complexity taking down astralis
not only did they beat astralis to make
their blast group grand finals
they 2-0 the best team in the world in
one of the game's greatest
upsets listen in my role as the esports
star i've seen every big cs goal match
ever i can tell you that would already
be like a top five upset of all time
think of the
disparity in the ranks between the two
teams i think astralis had only lost
something crazy like four
best of x series in the last like seven
tournaments they played something
so the idea that they get two zeroed
like this although they lost to navi in
the finals of their group
complexity showed the world the
potential this roster had
i don't know any team right now that can
do these results against one of the best
teams in the world so
i'm really i don't know i want to say
proud of complexity
i mean as i said before the meme
jogger now was a meme now it's not a
meme now it's
the future you know potential that was
reached a couple weeks ago
at the blast premier spring european
2020 finals
it's looking real good for complexion to
maybe close this out
oboe continuing the defense downstairs
and it's all on the shooter he's going
to get dropping 16 at 16-12
complexity are your champions ladies and
gentlemen amazing run here
at the blast premiere spring finals and
it'll be
it'll be complexity in the understand
told complexity did it
they finally won a big tournament and in
dominating fashion
they faced off against some of the best
teams in the world like faze clan
na'vi and vitality and they only dropped
three maps throughout the entire
tournament
with this win complexity shot up the hl
tv standings and are currently ranked
11th in the world
no longer an afterthought complexity or
changing minds across the scene
showing us that they're a force to be
reckoned with even in the highest levels
of competition
sure complexity aren't csgo juggernauts
just yet
and this is only one tournament but if
there's anything that we can take away
from this cinderella story
it's that jason lake kept his promise
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages